- Do you have advice for young minds today
dreaming about, creating
as you have dreamt,
creating intelligence systems?
What is the best way to arrive
at new breakthrough ideas
and carry them through
the fire of criticism
and past conventional ideas?
- Ask your questions.
Really, your questions are never dumb.
(laughs)
And so is your own way
and don't take no for an answer.
(chuckles)
If they're really dumb,
you will find out quickly,
by trial and error,
to see that they're not leading any place.
But, follow them and try to
understand things your way.
That is my advice.
I don't know if it's gonna help anyone.
- [Interviewer] No,
that's brilliantly put.
- There is a lot of
inertia
in science, in academia.
It is slowing down science.
- [Interviewer] Yeah
those two words: your way,
that's a powerful thing.
It's against inertia, potentially.
Against the full,
- [Older Man] Against your professor.
- Against your professor.
(laughs)
- I wrote a book of why,
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
In order to democratize common sense.
(both laugh)
In order to instill,
rebellious spirits in students.
So, they wouldn't wait until
the professor get things right.
(both laugh)
- [Interviewer] So,
you wrote the manifesto
"The Rebellion Against the Professor".
- [Older Man] Against the professor, yes.